now more than 100 miles away from here
in London at Sandringham estate William
and Kate greeted mourners and viewed
tributes to the queen and William also
talked about how yesterday solemn
marched behind the Queen's casket
brought back memories of his own
mother's death
King Charles had a private day of
reflection no public events so the rest
of the Royals fanned out across the UK
but not Harry and Megan today is Harry's
38th birthday and a source close to the
royal family tells E.T he's quote not
expected to do anything to Mark the day
except spend it privately however
consider this a little birthday gift
Palace officials have informed Harry he
can wear his military uniform at the
vigil on Saturday but as for his kids
Katie Nicola Royal expert joins me now
and tell me about the tip over the Royal
titles well for Archie and lilybert if
you go onto the Royal website at the
moment they do not have the hrh titles
yet if you're a betting woman will they
get those titles I think Charles will
make them Princeton princess but I also
think that's going to depend on a lot in
the future namely that King Charles can
trust Harry and Megan not to basically
trash the reputation of the royal family
he needs to be safe so we're not saying
don't make him a prince if you're saying
the title is what's going to affect
their protection our son needs to be
safe Harry's grandmother Queen will lie
in state until Monday's funeral
yesterday her cousin appeared to faint
and so did a guard
he's okay and come Monday the crowds
will be even bigger we're expecting more
than a million mourners to line the
procession route here in the Streets of
London behind us is Westminster Abbey
where the service will take place who
gets in and how many people so the
capacity of the Abbey is 2 000 people
this is a seriously vvip guest list I
just want to be in London I want to
experience it I want to share in the
ceremony of it that's the crowns Matt
Smith today the show which is currently
filming Princess Diana scenes in Spain
will suspend production Monday so we
could see its Stars at the funeral and
from Simon Cowell to Drew Barrymore more
celebs are reflecting on the monarchy I
have met um King Charles before and he
is the really nice man he's like a real
gentleman I had a dinner with um who's
now King Charles so fun a lot of Mayhem
ensued I accidentally grabbed Lucy Liu's
boob and and then there's other pictures
of him laughing hysterically he's so
funny